[Music]
let's go to aleona in south carolina
what's up eliana
hi dr john how are you i'm good how are
you
i am all right thank you of course how
are you
so
um
never mind i was going to ask you
something
totally unrelated so go ahead go ahead
um well first i would like to thank you
and your team and all mental health
professionals for
walking with us every day as we heal and
so we can better serve our communities
and our families i i really mean it with
all my heart and gratitude so thank you
hey i am running a like a podcast in a
radio show the truth therapists who are
in there seven hours eight hours a day
every day they're incredible yeah you
are right high five to them thank you so
much so what's up
so today i'm hoping that you can share
some thoughts on how i can best provide
mental and emotional support
um to my dear family and friends who are
currently
fighting for their lives and fighting
for their homes in the ukraine oh
man
tell me about what's going on
um
so i'm i'm very lucky and fortunate and
blessed to live here in the united
states
i do have some family that lives here
but
just like many ukrainians in america and
all over the world we also have family
and we have friends that are living in
in the ukraine and um
we are able to help them financially i'm
very blessed that i can
and we're sending humanitarian help
but normally if someone is having a hard
time i can sit here and
hold their hand and listen and
talk to talk to them but i i don't know
how to talk to my family i don't know
what to say to my friends because
saying sorry sounds stupid
in saying i understand i don't
i i don't understand
so i'm hoping that i can
find a way to be there for them
thousands of miles away and
maybe a way to be here for my family and
my community in the united states
they're also having a hard time
oh man well number one thank you for
sharing that and
you are intimately tied to this
tragedy that's going on and
um you're speaking on behalf of millions
who aren't as intimately tied they don't
have friends or family that are there
but they're just watching this and the
word that keeps going through my heart
and mind here is powerless
this sense that you are watching
bombs and tanks roll over your
neighborhoods and your homes and
children being born in bomb shelters and
things and this sense of powerlessness
you couldn't get there if you wanted to
right so there's there's just literally
nothing to do it's like watching
somebody drown and
you can't jump in right
and it's just that sense of
powerlessness and then you label i mean
you you put on top of that that
survivor's guilt
because you're doing you all are living
well in the u.s and there's a part of
you that thinks that feels bad about
that tell me about that
i
i
on what
i i learned this concept from you both
end
number one i am absolutely grateful
and blessed to be here and i'm grateful
that i am safe and my mama is safe my
father's safe
and i am
incredibly hurt and devastated and
guilty over the fact that i'm sitting
here in a
nice apartment with
you know with my dogs i i have a way to
pay my bills and even go to restaurants
and i
how how do how do you
i can't get over that i i
i just want i want to fly there and
fight that's what i want to do and
that's what many of us
absolutely yes if they said hey any uh
folks who want to hop on a plane we'll
fly you over
yes those planes would be packed
right so
um
i'm gonna speak super honestly with you
is that okay
of course okay
you are man you are a brave brave woman
i'm so grateful that you called
so
here's the bold statement i'm going to
say and i'm going to preface this with
this is a privilege statement this is a
fill in any kind of critique you want to
say about this statement
but this is the truth okay
right
there's nothing you can say to them
beyond i love you
with a period
you will not have peace
until this is over
period
your guilt
will not help them
the greatest gift you can give them
is joy
and living your life here and here's why
we often think that pain is some zero
and joy is some zero
and
if we've got a friend who is hurting a
friend who's in the hospital a friend
who's overseas while their home is being
invaded by a foreign country
that we need
to slide into that with them
and if they're our neighbor like you
said you're dang right man i'm going
into that house i'm gonna sit with them
in their ugliest moments i'm gonna make
casseroles and
cheap cookies and i'm gonna walk
alongside them
when it's one of these paralyzing
there's nothing we can do here
our instinct is to do the same
because our bodies aren't designed to
know in watch in real time on cell
phones something that's going on
15 000 miles away on the other side of
the world
and so our bodies have a pain and
and for loved ones and slide in to help
response and we are trying to do that
now and we can't
and we think that if we have if we laugh
if i go to a nice restaurant if i
do something romantic with my husband if
i fill in the blank
that somehow we are taking joy from them
right
and that couldn't be further from the
truth so flip it around
if you were there
would you want somebody who you loved
who had the the cosmic blessing of being
out of there
to just be miserable or would you want
them to go have dinner
oh i would want them to live their life
and i would join i would want them to
live wheels off
you better go out because i'm stuck here
in a bunker right you know what i mean
hey
and so
i want to challenge you to
put more beauty into the world
in a time when
millions of people are
um under fire and smoke and gray
put joy into the world put laughter into
the world put beauty into the world
where you can
lashing yourself
in order for camaraderie only results in
wounds on your back it doesn't help them
to hear what i'm saying yes yes ma'am
can i give you one other hard hard piece
of wisdom
oh absolutely and this is the pot
talking to the kettle here do you know
that expression
no but i am going to google it all right
here's what the pot talking to the
kettle is
this is somebody who is going to be very
hypocritical for a second
actually you know what i'm going to make
a commitment on this show with you if
you'll join me okay
since this kicked off
i have been obsessed
i have followed everything i've got a
curated twitter account i don't even
have twitter i go on the internets to
get through twitter but i follow a
curated feed
hours a day
i don't read the mainstream news because
they're not telling us the truth
whatever nonsense i've come up with and
i am obsessed with the talking to
military people talking to ukrainian
folks talking to russian i'm obsessed
with it
and here's what we have to do
we have to turn it off
right we have to turn it off
and that sounds so ugly and evil and
privileged in nonsense
we are not helping them
by just absorbing this 24 7 365.
the best thing we can do is be well
so that
we can rally people to provide money we
can tell the stories that aren't being
told we can write letters and they may
not get there
they may not make it there may not be a
mail service here that's going to get
them there we can write emails or we can
write texts that just say i love you i
love you i love you
i miss your face
not i'm sorry not um i understand yeah
none of that's true you're exactly right
i just i love you
and i'm putting beauty into the world
with your name on it
don't insert yourself into this combat
zone it doesn't help them it hurts you
can you and i make it make an agreement
that we're gonna cut back on how much
we're consuming
oh absolutely i um my family in general
and majority of our community that i am
around
we have
very consciously and intentionally
turned off
the news and we don't watch a lot of
news in general because everything we
need to know our friends and families
will tell us beautiful um
but
one thing that we are facing and this is
a product of misinformation
we are receiving a lot i mean
right now we're hurting our hearts are
breaking right
majority
majority of the people rallied around us
but we are receiving a lot of hate
from
misinformation the labs information
nazis etc like that makes it okay to
kill innocence people and children right
so what about that can you do anything
about
nothing at all
nothing at all you can turn
it's like people who are picketing
outside of a funeral
like i'm not gonna i'm not gonna give
you real estate in my head
i'm not gonna give you a voice at my
table
my friend died i don't care if you liked
him or not i'm gonna go in here and sit
with my friends family
and i'm gonna mourn and weep and then be
about honoring him and the best way i
know to honor people is to put beauty
into the world um
and to laugh and to go dancing and to
eat well and to make sure people around
me are honored
and to make sure i'm a part of a process
that never allows us to happen on the
dirt of where where i sleep
right right
and so um
yeah there's misinformation out there
it's hard when somebody says something
ugly or evil about people you love
especially people you love who are
hurting
we tend to flock to that
right right cut it off turn it off
i'm gonna block you i will never speak
to you again have a great life i wish
you the best may the force be with you
and whatever other star wars references
you want to put in their life
right i'm just i'm just gonna be done
with it i miss out thanks
don't get a voice in my heart in my head
you know who does
my friends and my family my community
and
when i'm able to get a text message or a
facetime with somebody who's sitting in
the middle of kiev and we can talk for a
minute
with sirens not going off i'm gonna
cherish that moment and i'm just gonna
listen and i'm gonna say i love you i
love you i love you and i'm planting
flowers with your name on them and i'm
gonna go plant flowers
um that's a great idea
blend sunflowers ukrainian flower
or whatever it is put beauty into the
world find get with your community with
your family with your friends and just
say where can we put beauty out here
number one we're going dancing
why because delony is the worst this guy
this podcast i listen to they don't
listen to it because it's not that great
but this podcast i listened to
um
he said to go dancing because he's a
terrible terrible terrible dancer and
the world needs a better dancer so we're
going dancing and we're going to plant
flowers this weekend
so everybody we're going to the nursery
like what you know you hear what i'm
saying i love love your heart
let's just turn it off and this is me
talking to myself in the mirror so thank
you for holding a mirror up to me today
aliana
you've been a gift to me as well
if there's something that um
what's one thing you can pass along to
us to me
you're talking to people who are there
that aren't on the radio that are just
moms and dads and brothers and sisters
trying to figure out what in the world
is happening
um what would you pass along to us
um
you know i
the only regrets and it's funny you said
to tell people that you love them the
only thing i was thinking of on february
24th is
what was my last conversation with my
sister
and my brother and my nieces and nephews
and
when was the last time i talked to my
dear friends
and it's that
right now i am trying to be intentional
about seeing my family here
in the united states and hugging my mom
closer because her
daughter is in the middle of the war and
my father's son is in the middle of the
war and
just hugging them closer
and letting go of things and spending
more time with our loved ones and
because
i don't i i was terrified that my last
conversation with my sister would have
been an argument and i couldn't remember
if i told her that i love her
and what will you never ever do as long
as you live again you'll never hang up
the phone without saying i love you will
you
never no never i haven't i still have
not can i cannot can i tell you
something i'm just keeping him with
delony wisdom which is i just give the
same pieces of advice over and over and
over again you know it'd be really cool
would be awesome if you and your mom and
dad went and
way
overpaid for a really nice leather
journal and every day y'all wrote
your brother and your sister a letter
how much you miss him how much you're
thinking about him and when this thing's
over
and y'all are able to reunite and hug
again
you'll be able to hand them that journal
and they'll be able to see
that in spirit and in heart y'all were
with them
and y'all planted flowers all along the
way
i would love that sound good
absolutely all right i'm going to do
something for you i'm going to give you
a copy of um this new book that's coming
out okay and it's not fully it'll be out
in storage by the time the show comes
out i think but
um it's here's here's the the genesis of
the book is or the thesis is
here's how to own what's the garbage
that's going on right now and then
here's what to do next okay
and you and your family can just walk
through it together here's what we do
now all right this knucklehead says to
do this all right let's do this
uh
how do we grieve here's a chapter on
great so it's just gonna be a playbook
for the next
five months five years right as this
thing plays itself out and i need you to
hear me say eliana
we're standing with you we're praying
with you
and you've got my commitment to plant
some flowers and to put some joy into
the world